insidious is back that's right he's back
whoever insidious is do you know what it
means the word I've tried using too many
times still don't know what it means
comment below let me know what insidious
means insidious chapter 2 yup the movies
back the movie franchise that scared the
[ __ ] out of you it made you [ __ ] in the
movie theaters all the seats were full
of [ __ ] back then in the year 2011 April
yep I remember that because it was a Q&A
in the audience so this movie it's it's
not getting as good a reviews as
insidious part one day to have people
are saying sounds fresh it's not as
scary and yes I do agree but you know
what I gotta say for a sequel to a
horror movie it's pretty damn solid I
mean for starters Patrick Wilson they
totally change up his character one you
know what makes him to have a lot of
range in this movie compared to all his
other films is she doesn't get naked at
all you know he's always naked in one of
his movies then I saw him city is home
for our song cities too and he was in
his underwear I'm like that's the
Patrick Wilson we know this one he
doesn't do it he really transforms in
this movie I would totally suck Patrick
Wilson's dick with his clothes on he is
actually really [ __ ] good in this
movie he has to play much darker role um
you know he's essentially playing two
characters in this film you know demon
haunting him and he does a really
excellent job he's kind of scary might
see a little bit jack michael sending
this movie it is not waiting to the
camera as much but he does do a great
job I mean there's a lot of things that
are solid about this i love it in the
terms of how it's a great part to like
they call this insidious chapter 2 and
that is the perfect title for it just
like how bad boys is the perfect title
for that movie because they are boys who
behave badly and they are black but
Sidious chapter 2 has that by because
it's a sequel that literally picks up
from where we left off like i saw the
first one moments before that saw the
second one and it just feels like the
story is continuing it feels like this
is the extended 90 minutes of the first
film and i like how they change it up a
lot to like it is
is more like a domestic thriller you
know kinda reminds it is shining in a
way what's just cool it that it
completes the story it's one of the few
sequels that actually seems necessary I
would say that if you saw the first one
you have to see this one in order to see
the story complete and James Wan's
directing the cinematography love it
it's those tracking shots where you're
like there's a that's like constant that
corner but the [ __ ] woman doesn't see
it goddamn rose burns always walking
around places that never [ __ ] notices
there's a ghost nearby idiot but you're
hot Rose Byrne [ __ ] hot look at you
dan the things i would do to you she was
an x-men first class more like x-men
nice ass she's also in bridesmaids more
like vagina and the effects the effects
are scary as ever to absolutely terrify
just the makeup effects alone will make
you piss your pants you will lose so
much water weight by the end of this
fell and the score the eerie little
Street she scored that right there gets
your heart moving you know a lot of
times with music plays in a horror movie
it surprisingly calms me down in this
particular film it amplifies the fear I
will say that there is some rather weak
riding there are moments that I just
really don't agree with it they be major
spoilers have actually spoke about them
there's sometimes where it's like that
was really convenient or I just don't
believe the character is capable of
doing that or that's a that's a little
cliche you know you get a lot of those
moments and it's not as terrifying as
the first one because they're going for
a different type of genre and one thing
that's went down to me too was like I
like these guys spec sins under I think
they're really funny but I thought it
was a little too funny like there's a
little too much comedy in this film for
me wait too much humor I wish I could go
into details but that'll ruin the movie
for you everyone does at the end it's
not as good as the first one it's not as
scary as the first one but throughout
the whole time it's very interesting
it's cool to see this story just
finished and continue its awesome seeing
these characters the acting is solid yes
there are a lot of things that don't
work about it but for the most part
everything's pretty damn good let me get
straight to the point here all i gotta
say insidious chapter 2 got it right
alright guys thanks for checking out our
review for insidious chapter 2 why don't
you go ahead scroll that comment box
below and tell me where can I find
Roseburg and if you want to go ahead and
follow me on Twitter you should click
the link right here huh it would be so
insidious did they use our rent and if
you want see more in depth review the
ultimate spoiler and depth review of
insidious chapter 2 go ahead and check
out my show called reasons to see that I
do have my buddy Jerry we have special
guest on the show Thomas he is Scottish
he is strong he is insidious still don't
know what that [ __ ] word means and
last one I least want to get updated
every time one of my reviews is out
going to click on this but if I my dick
to subscribe that's right this insidious
looking penis sounds hot doesn't it
sounds sexy insidious that means uh it's
an old wooden ship